bonjour à tous retour ce matin à une
audition qui s'est déroulée hier après
midi au sénat la commission des finances
a demandé à la cour des comptes
d'enquêté deux conomie mixte locale les
sociétés d'économie mixte locale
concerne directement plusieurs domaines
de notre quotidien comme le transport le
logement le tourisme ou bien encore le
développement économique
alsace aussi dans leur capital les
collectivités locales mais aussi des
actionnaires publics et privés la case
et d'époque possède de nombreuses
participations dans ce type de société
mais ces participations sont gérés par
des antennes régionales
conséquemment le système est très
nébuleux et complexes et donc ce grand
investisseur public ne sait pas toujours
où vos ses participations et donc les
risques associés
alors comment améliorer la gouvernance
de la caisse des dépôts
comment mieux sécuriser les risques dans
l'économie mixte locale
c'est l'objet de cette audition bien mes
chers collègues
si vous le voulez bien j'ouvre cette
nouvelle audition de suivi
audition de suivi d'une enquête réalisée
par la cour des comptes en application
de l'article 58 de la loi organique sur
les lois de finances et cette enquête
concerne les participations de la caisse
des dépôts et consignations dans
l'économie mixte locale
nous avons invité à cette audition nos
collègues de la commission des lois qui
ont récemment examiné la loi pour le
développement des sociétés publiques
locales dont notre collègue jacques
mézard était le rapporteur et qui est
présent et nos collègues de la
délégation sénatoriale aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
je vous rappelle que notre réunion est
ouverte à la presse
cette audition a une double raison
d'être puisque elle fait également suite
à la transmission à notre commission des
finances d'un rapport particulier de la
cour des comptes
je vous rappelle que nous avions décidé
lors du séminaire de l'aco
mission qui s'est tenue en 2007 au mans
en présence du premier président
philippe séguin de procéder à un suivi
plus systématique des rapports
particuliers et des référés qui nous
sont transmis par la cour des comptes et
qui ne font pas l'objet d'une publicité
sauf insertion ultérieure dans le
rapport public annuel la demande d'
enquête est venu compléter est venu
actualiser le rapport particulier dont
les travaux avaient débuté en 2008 dont
les conclusions nous le verrons avait
inspiré la caisse des dépôts et
consignations dans la réforme de
certaines procédures et nous auront
ainsi le privilège de constater que
certaines recommandations
sont d'ores et déjà suivies d'effet
outre l'actualisation de l'étude sur le
pilotage des sociétés d'économie mixte
de la caisse des dépôts et consignations
déjà engagées par la cour des comptes la
demande dans quel 58,2 visait
principalement à apporter 3 série
d'informations que je voudrais rappeler
d'abord établir une typologie des
sociétés d'économie mixte concernées
ainsi qu un bilan de la diversité de
leur statut et de leur évolution
juridique
en second lieu mesurer la valeur ajoutée
apportée par la caisse des dépôts et
consignations dans ce type d'activité on
regarde la gouvernance ou des modes de
financement et apprécier la sincérité et
la traduction dans les contes et les
budgets des partenaires notamment des
collectivités territoriales de l'appui
de la caisse des dépôts et consignations
et enfin porter une appréciation sur la
nouvelle doctrine d'intervention de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations sur
sa politique d'arbitrage sur le stock de
participation et sur les problèmes liés
à l'application du droit de la
concurrence
à cette fin nous recevons pour la cour
des comptes
le président de la première chambre
monsieur christian aguzou messieurs jean
de gaulle emmanuel dur est conseillé m
et madame martine ullmann rapporteur la
caisse des dépôts et consignations est
représentée par monsieur michel bouvard
président de la commission de
surveillance
augustin de romanet -directeur général
également madame briques qui est membre
de la commission de surveillance mais
elle siège ici en sa qualité de
commissaire des finances la direction
générale du trésor est également
présente
l autorité de tutelle de la caisse des
dépôts et consignations elle est
représentée par monsieur hervé de
villeroché chef du service du
financement de l'économie
il nous a également paru utile de
solliciter la direction générale des
collectivités locales qui représentait
par monsieur bruno del sol adjoint au
directeur général des collectivités
locales
j'ai pour ma part une double
préoccupation concernant la question
abordée par l' enquête de la cour des
comptes
je souhaite en premier lieu que cette
enquête permette de fournir des
informations fiables
sur le secteur d'activité qui forgent
depuis longtemps des relations que
j'aurais envie de qualifier deux
complices entre les collectivités
territoriales et la caisse des dépôts et
consignations il est important
me semble-t-il de prendre la mesure de
l'importance ou de la modestie des
sommes en jeu et d'appliquer à ce
secteur un minimum de principes de
gestion en toute connaissance de cause
je suis conscient que la présence des
représentants de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations dans les conseils
d'administration des sociétés d'économie
mixte est un apport considérable à la
bonne gouvernance desdites sociétés dans
le rapport particulier qu'elle a
transmis à la commission des finances la
cour compte des comptes notait en
particulier que pour 12 % du
portefeuille en volume
le taux de participation de la caisse
est inférieure à 5 % du montant investi
inférieur à quinze mille euros
elle mettait l'accent également sur un
taux de rendement très faible de l'ordre
de 0 3 à 0 4 % pour les seules sociétés
d'économie mixte qui distribuent des
dividendes et tout ne distribuent pas de
dividendes
elle faisait état en fin d'une
caractérisation des risques peu
satisfaisante qui plaçait 40% des
sociétés d'économie mixte locale sous le
statut de sensible ces observations ont
conduit évidemment a souligné le
caractère de coisy subventions des
participations de la caisse des dépôts
et consignations dans l'économie locale
manifestement une certaine évolution est
en train de se faire jour à l'initiative
de la caisse évolution stimulée par la
cour des comptes
il est souhaitable d'en faire le point
la seconde préoccupation porte sur la
volatilité de l'environnement juridique
qui a connu deux mouvements majeurs
d'une part le durcissement des
contraintes de mise en concurrence à la
fois internes et européennes et d'autre
part l'apparition de nouvelles
structures qui s'ajoute où se substitue
aux sociétés d'économie mixte la caisse
des dépôts et consignations pour sa part
intervient dans l'économie locale en
usant d'autres formules juridiques
société anonyme société anonyme
simplifier société civile immobilière
société de projet alors que les
collectivités territoriales souhaite
plus d'autonomie plus de simplicité dans
les procédures en utilisant des sociétés
publiques locales spl sorte de coisy
régit la question posée est donc bien
celle de l'avenir de ce mode
d'intervention qui n'est peut-être plus
adaptée à notre temps afin de préserver
une possibilité effective de dialogue et
de débat je demande aux intervention
liminaire de chacun de se limiter aux
observations principal la parole sera
successivement aux magistrats de la cour
des comptes
d'abord ensuite aux représentants de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations pour
leurs observations sur les analyses que
présente la cour des comptes et enfin
aux représentants de la direction
générale du trésor et de la direction
générale des collectivités territoriales
nous devons être d'autant plus
synthétique et que le directeur général
de la caisse des dépôts et consignations
à des engagements impératif ors du sénat
autour de 17h30 je crois chaque
commissaire bien sûr qu'il le souhaitera
pour enfin poser ses questions
je rappelle aux membres de la commission
des finances que nous aurons à l'issue
de ce débat à prendre une décision sur
la publication de l'enquète de la cour
des comptes au sein d'un rapport
d'information ayant dit cela
la parole pour commencer et donc au
président de la première chambre
christian babusiaux merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
les travaux que nous avons mené
à la vôtre demande et qui font l'objet
de cette séance s'inscrivent dans le
prolongement de travaux qui est que nous
avions mené il y a quelques mois à la
propre initiative de la cour sur le
pilotage des participations de la caisse
des dépôts dans les sociétés d'économie
mixte de local à ses investigations
avaient donné lieu à un rapport
particulier au sens de la procédure de
contrôle des entreprises publiques dont
la synthèse est d'ailleurs jointe à la
communication qui a été adressée à votre
commission ce rapport particulier
comportait dix neuf recommandations et
il a d'ores et déjà contribué à ce que
s'enclenche un processus d'amélioration
en matière de contrôle interne et de
pilotage du portefeuille qu'il s'agisse
du système d'information de gestion des
métiers du suivi des cem sensible et de
la politique de provisionnement des
processus d'engagement ou encore de la
prévention des risques
ces améliorations nous avons pu les
constater à l'occasion de la nouvelle
enquête que vous avez demandé à la cour
en outre dans ce rapport rédigé à votre
demande
la cour s'est efforcée d'approfondir
d'autres points notamment l'apport des
sociétés d'économistes de local au
développement local et la nouvelle
doctrine définie par la caisse dans son
plan stratégique élan 2020
notre rapport prend aussi en compte les
évolutions juridiques récente que vous
avez rappelé monsieur le président est
le point de vue des principales
associations de collectivités
territoriales que nous avons entendu
quatre points saillants dans cette
communication
tout d'abord la présence de la caisse
des dépôts au capital de ces sociétés
d'économie mixte locale résulte
largement de l'histoire et son
importance relative est désormais assez
limité la caisse des dépôts certes
dispose aujourd'hui d'un portefeuille de
440 de participation d'une valeur de 222
millions en coûts historiques et de 590
en quote-part d'actif net comptable
détenus et elle est ainsi présente au
capital de 42 % des cem locales recensés
par la fédération des entreprises
publiques locales
l'importance de ce portefeuille est
toutefois à relativiser il ne représente
en effet qu'un peu plus de 1% de la
valeur d'acquisition des participations
de l'établissement public au 31 décembre
2009 donc c'est petit aujourd'hui ce
portefeuille résulte de la sédimentation
de plusieurs époques et portent
fortement la marque de la période de
reconstruction de l'après-guerre et de
la politique d'aménagement du territoire
des années 1960
cet investissement est concentrée dans
le secteur de l'immobilier résidentiel à
lui seul près de la moitié des
participations de la caisse pour centrer
aussi dans quelques régions et dont
l'île de france rhône alpes provence
côte d'azur pays de loire sans oublier
l'outre-mer en nombre de participations
c'est le secteur de l'aménagement qui
domine puisque la caisse est présente au
capital depuis de 60% des scènes locales
d'aménagement
ce portefeuille comprend par ailleurs
près d'un tiers de société d'économie
mixte locale dit faîtière 127 sociétés
faîtières qui détiennent elle-même près
de 320 participation au statut juridique
très
varié et dont la caisse est souvent
aussi un actionnaire direct par ailleurs
la structure du portefeuille traduit
avant tout la volonté de la caisse de
répondre aux sollicitations des
collectivités locales sans avoir
toujours su du moins jusqu'à une période
récente faire prévaloir des axes
stratégiques
il en est résulté un portefeuille qui
peut sembler hétérogène du fait d'une
forte dispersion des montants investis
des taux de détention et d'une grande
diversité des scènes locales de gestion
pour autant ce portefeuille n'est pas
seulement un simple héritage historique
ils permettent encore à la caisse et à
ses filiales d'entretenir un réseau
local essentiel dans le secteur de
l'économie mixte
elle s'est d'ailleurs attaché à mettre
fin aux situations de conflit d'intérêts
qui étaient parfois dénoncé
antérieurement par les chambres
régionales des comptes et plusieurs
sociétés du groupe caisse des dépôts
prestataires des cem locales avaient
adopté nous le savons et vous le savez
bien de très longue date un modèle de
travail en réseau qui n'était pas
dépourvu d'ambiguïté il y a été
largement remédier mais çà et là
subsiste des risques de conflits
d'intérêts qui n'ont pas donc encore
totalement disparu deuxième point
saillant c'est que les risques
financiers supportés par l'actionnaire
caisse des dépôts restent au total
limité
l'implication de la caisse des dépôts
dans l'économie mixte locale ne consiste
pas seulement dans des prises de
participation minoritaires mais
également dans l'octroi de prêts sur
fonds d'épargné pour 5,2 milliards en
2009 et de près de la direction bancaire
pour 339 millions d'euros
cependant ces activités de sur fonds
d'épargné ou de banquiers court terme
présente des risques limités globalement
maîtrisé en effet les processus
d'engagement s'appuie sur des procédures
et des délégations de compétence
normes et est bien rodé le dispositif de
contrôle interne a beaucoup progressé
depuis 2008 les prêts sur fonds
d'épargné sont en outre couvert par de
larges garanties publiques
la limitation des risques de la caisse
au titre de son activité bancaire repose
quand thèse sur une connaissance précise
des scènes locales par le réseau même si
cette connaissance n'exclut pas tout
risque de défaut le réseau bancaire de
surcroît ne cherche pas à conquérir des
parts de marché au détriment de la
maîtrise de ces risques le risque
investisseurs est également limitée pas
le taux de détention toujours
minoritaire du capital décès mme locca
la contrepartie évidemment et que
l'essentiel du risque éventuel de moeurs
sur les collectivités locales et leurs
groupements en leur qualité de garant
mais pour ce qui concerne la caisse un
processus d'amélioration du concerne
interne et la mise en oeuvre des règles
prudentielles dites de bâle iii
conduisent à limiter les risques liés à
ce portefeuille
troisième point saillant assez que l'as
l'environnement juridique et financier
dans lequel s'inscrivent les cem locales
et leurs actionnaires et instable il
s'agit en premier lieu du contexte
juridique vient en effet voulu rappeler
monsieur le président d'intervenir la
loi du 29 mai 2010 relative au
développement des sociétés publiques
locales
son impact sur le portefeuille reste
difficile à appréhender avec précision
nous avons à cet égard auditionné
beaucoup d'acteurs et on voit bien que
l'impact exact ne pourra sans doute se
dégager davantage que d'ici peut-être au
moins une bonne année alors il semble
cependant que les transformations de sem
locale en spl où s p est là seront plus
nombreuses pour les petites scènes
municipal et dans le secteur de
l'aménagement que pour les autres types
de sociétés le souci de des
collectivités de travailler avec des
aménageurs
quelle honte ou auront elle même créée
qui leur seront propres devrait en effet
les conduire à utiliser les nouvelles
possibilités ouvertes par la loi
parallèlement il se peut que les
communes transforme de petites scènes
locales en effet elle
pour simplifier leur gouvernance mais
tout aussi important que l'environnement
juridique est le contexte financier les
acteurs de l'économie mixte évolue dans
un contexte marqué par des contraintes
financières forte aussi bien pour la
caisse que pour les collectivités la
caisse des dépôts attend désormais de
ces investissements une rentabilité
financière à long terme alors que pour
l'instant son portefeuille vous le
rappeliez ne génère que très peu de
dividendes elle prévoit même d'essayer
d'autofinancer à l'avenir une part
importante de ces investissements dans
cette économie mixte la caisse souhaite
donc accroître la rotation de son
portefeuille par la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique de rationalisation visant à se
recentrer sur les scènes à enjeu ce qui
constitue une rupture par rapport au
passé
la caisse se heurtent cependant au
caractère très illiquides de ce
portefeuille
la cour a également constaté que ce
portefeuille ne représentent qu'une
faible part des investissements
d'intérêt général de la caisse entre 1
et 6 % de 2004 à 2009 et cette tendance
semble appelée à se confirmer à l'avenir
puisque la caisse ne prévoit d'y
investir que 3 à 5 % du montant total
des investissements d'intérêt général
programmée pour 2010 à 2012 pour
apprécier les évolutions en cours dans
ce contexte juridique et économique
évolutif mais contre un il faut enfin
tenir compte de la stratégie désormais
clarifiée par la caisse et ce sera le
quatrième point saillant que je
soulignerai
efforts en effet pour fixer un cadre
stratégique claire cet effort a permis
de rendre plus lisibles les doctrines
d'action de la caisse des dépôts comme
investisseur avisé d'intérêt général
pour reprendre l'expression désormais
utilisé par la caisse cette
clarification des principes
d'intervention s'est accompagnée de la
réorganisation en 2008 de la direction
compétente de la caisse avec notamment
la création d'un département dédié grâce
à la professionnalisation du métier
d'investisseur et depuis l'instauration
d'un corps de doctrine d'actions
l'établissement public est en mesure de
mieux affirmer ses principes
d'intervention dans les projets
structurants des collectivités
territoriales et de rationaliser les
différents segments de son portefeuille
par une politique d'arbitrage des lignes
non stratégiques
les investissements sont désormais
concentrés sur les secteurs mis en avant
dans le plan stratégique élan 2020 les
universités l'économie de la
connaissance le développement durable
les énergies renouvelables le
développement numérique du territoire le
logement ou encore la politique de la
ville cela d'ailleurs sens que la forme
juridique utilisé soit nécessairement
une société d'économie mixte locale la
nouvelle stratégie de la caisse la
conduira à restreindre sa participation
à un nombre limité de projets
sélectionnés
non seulement en fonction de leur
rentabilité financière à long terme mais
aussi sous l'angle de leur efficacité
socio-économique que la caisse cherche
désormais à mesure et pour ce faire elle
a développé une grille de cotation
d'intérêt général des projets qui
méritent certes encore d'être affinés
elle met également l'accent sur sa
participation à la gouvernance des cem
local au travers d'une charte de
l'administrateur de l'administrateur et
de pacte d'actionnaires
encore ne tourne ou que à ce jour le
nombre des pactes d'actionnaires
moeurs restreint mais l'orientation
semble prise le succès de ces nouvelles
orientations reste un objectif de long
terme au plan local
laquelle se trouve en effet sollicité
par les collectivités et doit aussi
tenir compte des contingences locales
elle doit dans le même temps gérer son
stock de participation ancien faiblement
rentables peu liquide
enfin la démarche d'évaluation des
investissements d'intérêt général doit
être développée thèses sont monsieur le
président les points saillants de cette
communication
globalement elles me semblent
relativiser les risques encourus par la
caisse constaté que des efforts très
réelles ont été réalisés par saisie pour
rationaliser ses participations montré
que les évolutions juridiques
financières et stratégiques convergent
vers une diminution de l'importance de
ces réseaux est dégagée in fine et les
directions dans lesquelles les
améliorations doivent à notre sens se
poursuivre
merci monsieur le président donc nous
avons bien bien entendu les quatre
observations principal que vous avez
formulé les quatre points saillants
je vais donner la parole maintenant on
directeur général au président du
conseil la commission de surveillance
construit pour et nous confirme que vous
foncez pas un enjeu financier c c'est un
ticket de partenariat local une coisy
subventions à l'animation économique
local ce président michel chers
collègues
quelques mots pour tout être avant d'en
venir au contenu même du rapport et en
réponse à vos questions sur un aspect
sur lequel nous avions eu l'occasion
d'échanger qui concerne la bonne
utilisation des travaux de la cour des
comptes par la commission de
surveillance
de la caisse des dépôts puisque nous
avons la chance de bénéficier outre de
la présence intuitu personae de
magistrats de la cour au sein de la
commission de surveillance de pouvoir
bénéficier de rapport effectué par la
cour au titre du contrôle des
entreprises publiques de l'état et donc
le rapport sur les scènes tel qu'il a
été fourni en 2008 bien évidemment comme
tous les rapports de la cour de lieux un
cas suivie par la commission de
surveillance qui consacre d'ailleurs
l'une de ces séances chaque année et dès
les premiers échanges que nous avons eus
une partie des travaux ont été utilisés
bien évidemment pour conforter la
démarche qui a été engagé par la
commission de surveillance au début de
cette mandature en parfaite harmonie
avec le directeur général consistant à
améliorer la mesure de l'efficacité des
investissements de la caisse et de la
qualité de ses investissements je
voudrais à ce point mater roger très
courtoisement par rapport à nos
collègues sénateurs sur la méthodologie
de nos commandes respectives de rap
ordre puisque les rapports particuliers
ont effectivement vocation à être connu
des commissions des finances de
l'assemblée du sénat être mieux
exploitées nous avons souhaité aussi
j'en avais fait part au président
philippe séguin et on a évoqué cette
question avec le premier président
didier migaud le souhait que sans que la
commission de surveillance qui est une
émanation quelque part du parlement est
un droit de tirage comme les assemblées
parlementaires en termes de commandes de
rapports auprès de la cour des comptes
que nous puissions avoir au moment où
celle-ci élabore son programme de
travail également la capacité d'exprimer
un certain nombre de sous et sur des
sujets denquête qui pourraient être
utiles aux travaux de la commission de
surveillance dans son rôle de protection
et de contrôle de la caisse des dépôts
puisque je précise c'est bien le
parlement qui exerce la tutelle sur la
caisse des dépôts la direction du trésor
exerçant la surveillance pour le compte
de l'état mais la tutelle est bien une
tutelle du parlement alors ceci étant et
après avoir salué le travail de la cour
à la fois sur le premier rapport est
sûre le 58 2 qui sont des travaux
concordants je voudrais comme l'a fait
le président babusiaux souligné d'abord
qu'une partie des observations qui ont
été formulées ont d'ores et déjà été
prises en compte qu'il ya eu d'ailleurs
une réactivité forte et même une
anticipation des services de la caisse
au niveau de la direction du
développement territorial et du réseau
de la direction des fonds d'épargné de
la direction bancaire la commission de
surveillance ayant depuis trois ans
impulsé cette volonté d'évaluation et de
mesures quantitatives des
investissements le champ des scènes
faisant partie de notre champ de
préoccupation mais étant comme cela a
été souligné marginal par rapport à la
totalité des investissements de la
caisse un certain nombre de
recommandations qu'il appartiendra au
directeur général de détail et ont
d'ores et déjà été prise en compte pour
les autres la nouvelle organisation de
la direction territoriale et du réseau
et la rénovation des systèmes
d'information de la direction des fonds
d'épargné comme la direction bancaire
devrait permettre de concrétiser ses
progrès en 2011 et permettre à la
commission de surveillance de bénéficier
de davantage d'éléments sur la
motivation des investissements nous
sommes dans le cadre des missions
d'intérêt général les missions d'intérêt
général je le rappelle sont prévues
comme une obligation qui fait à la
caisse des dépôts au travers de la loi
de modernisation de l'économie
et s'agissant de missions d'intérêt
général il est somme toute naturel que
la recherche de rentabilité soit
différente de celle que nous pouvons
refaire chez sur des portefeuilles
d'investissement totalement libre qui
contribue donc à permettre à la caisse
des dépôts de dégager un résultat
significatif chaque année de conforter
ainsi ses fonds propres
d'avoir une capacité d'investissement
ainsi qu'une capacité de versement d'une
contribution à l'état donc s'agissant
évidemment des investissements qui sont
faits dans l'est
cm nous sommes dans le cadre de ses
missions d'intérêt général nous sommes
aussi dans un cadre il faut le souligner
qui est un cadre de scène c'est à dire
il s'agit de structurer une part de
capital privé au capital décès mais la
présence de la caisse des dépôts est
souvent un élément déterminant pour
faciliter l'entrée au capital de ces
scènes d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
financiers locaux à compeyre commencer
par les établissements bancaires qui se
trouvent dans les régions concernées
c'est aussi pour les élus et je pense
que tous ceux qui ont des cem dans leur
collectivité en seront conscients une
garantie d'avoir une gouvernance qui
soit une gouvernance équilibrée avec des
administrateurs qui peuvent apporter une
vision extérieure et donc alerté les
responsables des collectivités sur les
prises de risques alors ceci bien
évidemment dans mon esprit dans l'esprit
de la commission de surveillance
nicole bricq pourrait en attester qu'ils
aient une membre assidu des travaux de
la commission et des comités spécialisés
ça n'interdit pas qu'il y ait des
stratégies c'est ce qui a été mis en
place en s'efforçant de fait de faire en
sorte que les cem s'inscrivent dans les
démarches dès l'an 2020 avec les
priorités telles qu'elles ont été
proposées par la direction générale et
avec lesquels la commission de
surveillance a marqué son accord
ça n'interdit pas bien évidemment aussi
qu'il y à une rotation du portefeuille
même si bien évidemment nous butons sur
une certaine liquidité des titres et
qu'il y ait aussi une rationalisation de
la cartographie des sem
je voudrais dire par exemple que cette
rationalisation lors d'un déplacement
récent que j'ai l'occasion de faire en
région languedoc-roussillon qu'on a en
général à faire un des élus qui sont
conscients des limites de capacité d'un
certain nombre de l'ours m à des
directeurs régionaux de la caisse qui en
sont heureux tout à fait milite
militants pour cette rationalisation
mais il est vrai que il est parfois
difficile d'organiser les regroupements
dans un délai court était prééminence de
gouvernance entre collectivités peuvent
jouer néanmoins
je crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui cette
prise de conscience d'un besoin de
rationalisation de la cartographie des
cem et donc voit ainsi que cette les
recommandations qui sont faites au
travers du rapport de la cour soit ont
été prises en compte soit ont même été
devancés où se sont trouvées en
concordance avec les démarches engagées
par la commission de surveillance je
voudrais enfin avant de laisser la
parole au directeur général dire un
dernier mot de la loi de mars 2010 sur
la création des dsp elle qui doit
effectivement pas contaminer les actions
de pilotage décidée par la caisse
il y à des doctrines d'investisseur
avisé qui ont été rénovées qui sont
appliquées en région comme au siège il
n'ya une charte de l'administrateur
il ya une information des directions
régionales sur les enjeux de cette
nouvelle option avec le risque en
quelque sorte de ce que j'appellerais
une double peine pour la caisse à savoir
la dégradation de ses intérêts
patrimoniaux détenus dans les cem au
bénéfice de spl une décote de la valeur
des sessions de celles qui sont déjà pas
forcément facile ceci étant il faut
limiter
il faut limiter la préhension qu'on peut
avoir par rapport à cette affaire
plus de 400 cm dans lesquels la caisse
des dépôts est actionnaire en face 40
spl où s p est là et au travers
également des contacts que l'on a pu
avoir dans les directions régionales au
cours d'un certain nombre de
déplacements
on s'est aperçu que l'intention des élus
locaux étaient souvent une
transformation de régis un outil
permettant de gérer avec plus de
souplesse des services municipaux plutôt
qu'une inscription en concurrence par
rapport à un certain nombre de ce style
économiques dans lesquels ils étaient
eux mêmes partenaires ceci étant le
parlement a adopté cette loi ce n'est
pas la caisse qui en est à l'origine
et là
je pense à juste titre aujourd'hui
lancer une analyse sur ce thème pour
regarder comment notre action peut
s'inscrire dans ce cadre modifié et la
commission de surveillance bien
évidemment quand sera saisie comme elle
est saisie chaque année des actions de
la direction du développement
territorial et du réseau auquel nous
pendant grande attention
la dernière séance à ce sujet là c'était
le 24 mars est bien évidemment à cette
occasion nous évoquons maintenant le
sujet des sociétés d'économie mixte 1%
encore une fois des actifs c'est
relativement peu une prise de risque
limitée mais il faut être vigilant sur
certains secteurs notamment sur les sem
d'aménagement avec les problématiques de
portage foncier qui peuvent et quelques
modifications législatives et
réglementaires qui peuvent avoir des
incidences ont néanmoins nous sommes sur
un sujet qui est tout en étant
importants dans le monde de l'économie
mixte est un sujet qui je dirais est
limitée au regard des missions qui sont
celles de la commission de surveillance
c'est à dire de veiller aux orientations
stratégiques de l'établissement et aux
risques qu'ils sont pris par celui ci
merci monsieur le président mais au fond
la transformation des hommes en société
publique locale
c'est le désinvestissement parce que
dans ces cas dans cette hypothèse là la
caisse ne peut rester actionnaire oui
alors quand il a alors qu'en fait on a
deux phénomènes on a des créations de
spl grèce fait elle à aix ni l'eau sans
transformation et puis à quelques
endroits il y à des transformations
effectivement les transformations c'est
se disait porte un risque de double
peine
en sachant qu'il y a bien évidemment
compte tenu de l'illiquidité en plus des
actions qu'on a dans les cem bon un
risque de valorisation insuffisante mais
la relation de la caisse au travers de
ses directions régionales avec les
collectivités territoriales dont elle
est un partenaire important en matière
d'apport d'ingénérie en matière de co
investissement fait je pense que ce
risque est limité parce que il n'ya pas
que l'essai me lie à tous les autres
aspects de partenariat avec les
collectivités qui font que les
collectivités je pense ont la sagesse
aussi de trouver les bons équilibres
dans ce cas là merci monsieur durban est
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
vous compte tenu de l'exhaustivité du
rapport de monsieur babusiaux et de ce
qu'a dit le président pouvoir jouer bref
je prendrais simplement quatre têtes de
chapitres évoqué par monsieur babusiaux
conclusion je dirai un mot sur les sprl
s p lan sur le l'importance financière
des cem dans le portefeuille d'actifs de
la caisse des dépôts il est juste
effectivement de dire que le risque est
limité notre valeur d'achat était de 238
millions d'euros et notre valeur d'actif
net est estimé à 636 millions d'euros de
mémoire l'actif long la crise et des
points et 7 45 milliards d'euros
donc effectivement il s'agit d'une d'une
somme qui n'est pas significative au
regard des risques de l'établissement
néanmoins lorsque en 2007 je suis
arrivée avec les peaux j'avais été
frappé par le fait que les
participations de la maison dans les cem
apparaissait un peu comme des biens de
main morte dont il était légitime de
considérer qu'elles avaient une valeur
de revente aux collectivités locales
égal à la valeur nominale des titres ça
vous donnera une idée de la rigueur avec
laquelle ces
ces comptes étaient suivis ce qui m'a
fait craindre que le détail de la
connaissance des comptes des cem soit
insuffisant ce qui nous a conduits avec
lili brady a décidé de la création de ce
qu'on a appelé un infocentre on a décidé
de créer une base informatique qui nous
permet de savoir à tout moment quelle
est la valeur d'actif net des cem
information qui n'était pas connu à
l'époque et de connaître l'ensemble de
la vie sociale des cem c'est que nous
avons désormais une base de données vous
avez dû je pense ausculté qui permet de
savoir pour chaque cm les augmentations
de capital les réductions de capital et
distribution dividendes etc etc
donc cette meilleure connaissance de
decem nous a permis lorsque incertain ou
de d'élus locaux nous ont demandé de
vendre leurs parts de faire valoir nos
droits de façon tout à fait normale en
ayant finalement accordé très peu
d'exceptions dans certains cas précis il
était il a été quand même nécessaire
d'accepter devant nos titres en dessous
de la valeur réelle
parce que l'ensemble du milieu local
observer une coutume qui était de vendre
à vil prix
et lorsque les lequel venait nous voir
dans dix ans mais les caisses d'epargne
le crédit mutuel et l autre tiers
acceptent de vendre les titres à la
valeur d'actif net divisé par deux il
était difficile pour nous d'être plus
royaliste que le roi
donc les risques relatifs je suis
d'accord les efforts de connaissances
effectivement c'est un effort qui doit
être poursuivi
la convergence vers moins de risques
j'ai noté effectivement que la cour des
comptes ou des faits une multitude
d'observation pertinente des
observations dix à quinze notamment
quant à l'amélioration des procédures de
contrôle des risques
nos participations dans les cem et
effectivement le souci que nous avons
eues à la caisse des dépôts en 2007 en
sur le plan élan 2020
c'est de ne jamais être dans une
situation de pouvoir ou de vouloir
implanter la caisse des dépôts dans un
dossier pour des logiques de pouvoir
nous ne venons dans un dossier qu à la
seule condition qu'un est le cas nous le
demande et non seulement qui nous le
demandent mais qu'en plus ça rentre en
cohérence avec nos priorités
stratégiques c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons dégagé une grille de
cotation de dépenses d'intérêts généraux
les deux cotations nous avons exporté
auprès du fonds stratégique
d'investissement pour pour la formation
de la commission et qu'on pourrait leur
exportation exporté je pense dans
d'autres domaines
cette grille de cotation nous permet de
savoir si un investissement est utile au
regard de deux principaux critères qui
sont d'une part de critère de l'intérêt
général qui est évidemment un critère
discutable mais nous partageons avec les
locaux et d'autre part le critère de
l'investisseur avisé étant acquis que
nous acceptons pour les investissements
dans les cem des taux de rendement qui
sont en bas de la fourchette du marché
c'est à dire que nous acceptons des taux
de rendement qui peuvent être de 5 6% et
encore sur une très longue durée
donc nous partageons évidemment les
recommandations de la cour des comptes
quant à l'amélioration des règles de
cotation que nous poursuivons alors sur
les sp la spl je crois que le risque
entre guillemets pour nous est égal à
zéro puisque encore une fois n'étant pas
dans une logique de pouvoir si du jour
au lendemain on nous demandait de vendre
toutes nos participations dans les sem
nous n'aurions aucune angoisse
à ce sujet je pense que la structure
juridique de la scène est très utile en
ce qu'elle permet à la collectivité
locale de se confronter à la logique de
marché et d'ailleurs je regrette que la
fédération des entreprises locales n'est
pas plus de rayonnement à l'échelle du
pays
parce que je crois que localement il
existe des expériences de sem qui sont
absolument remarquable en ce qui
concerne l'aménagement urbain ou
développement économique des territoires
et jamais la fédération des opm
maintenant là me semble-t-il porter ce
message assez haut et nous caisse des
dépôts nous sommes très désireux de
nouer un partenariat solide avec la
fédération des établissements plus que
le coup alors s'agissant des dsp là je
me ferai un petit plaisir de vous livrer
la liste des inconvénients qui peut
exister pour une collectivité locale de
passer de la hesse de l'asem à la spl je
vous livre d'autant plus cette liste
d'inconvénients qu'il s'agit non pas
pour moi de dire aux collectivités
locales de ne pas en créer après tout
elles font ce qu'elles veulent mais il
s'agit simplement d'être conseils pour
leur dire que si d'aventuré elle veut
créer une spl a plutôt qu'une scène elle
se prive de l'expertisé d'un partenaire
financier motivés qui se se considère
comme devant être un investisseur avisé
elle prive investisseur public d'un
apporteur de fonds propres puisque comme
vous le voyez la caisse des dépôts n'est
en réalité pas limité pour apporter des
fonds propres aux scènes comme l'a dit
le président babusiaux ces 3 5% nos
dépenses d'intérêt général nos dépenses
d'intérêt général c'est 500 millions
d'euros par an donc ça veut dire que nos
dépenses en faveur des scènes c'est de
l'ordre d'une quinzaine de millions
d'euros par an si demain matin il y
avait une forte demande des
collectivités locales pour doublé doublé
son montant il serait probablement
possible d'y accéder donc elle se prive
de l'expertisé d'un partenaire elle se
prive d'un apport en fonds propres
elle se prive de l'effet de levier de
l'apport d'actionnaires privés
il n'y a plus de partage de risque entre
actionnaires publics et privés elle ne
peut pas elles ne peuvent pas intervenir
en dehors de leur champ de compétence
près précisé par les statuts
puisqu'elles ont le statut de société in
house l'absence de mise en concurrence
ne pousse pas l'entreprise à la
performance il ya une perte de
contradictions au sein des conseils
d'administration des établissements
entre actionnaires privés et actionnaire
public et j'en passe et je pourrai
encore développer les inconvénients qui
peuvent exister de se développer
asp elle a donc pour conclure je dirais
que il me semble que l'exercice auquel
la cour des comptes s'est livrée et
auquel votre commission s'est intéressé
en demandant ce 58,2 est
particulièrement précieux dans la mesure
où il permet à chacun d'entre nous
d'être tout à fait au clair sur ce qu'il
est possible de faire ou pas avec une
sem et de d'être en mesure de délivrer
aux autorités locales
une position qui soit dénué de tous
rapports de pouvoir mais qu'ils soient
marquées du souci de la meilleure
efficacité locales et encore une fois je
ne vois pas pourquoi on devrait se
priver de cet outil de l'asem qui dans
beaucoup de cas est le seul moyen pour
une collectivité locale de se confronter
aux rigueurs certes mais aussi haut
conséquence d'efficacité qui sont
attachés à la rencontre du marché
bien merci monsieur le directeur général
donc nous voyons bien que c'est un
certain maurice quelques gestion était
déjà exemplaire mais que sous la
pression de la caisse
elle est allée d'emblée vers
l'excellence est-ce que je peux
solliciter l'avis de la direction du
trésor sur ces sociétés d'économie mixte
locale et la vision que vous avez
monsieur le directeur de l'évolution est
ce que finalement ces sociétés publiques
locales vont prendre corps est ce que la
circulaire qui allait proposer monsieur
ma relaxe va enfin être publié merci
monsieur le président j'ai peut-être
plus plus généralement réagir sur le
rapport lui-même et la question de
l'intervention de la caisse des dépôts
dans ses activités m'ont le premier
point c'est que nous souscrivons très
globalement aux conclusions et très
généralement conclusions du rapport de
la crau je dirais que ces interventions
pour nous sont logiques
dans le cadre des missions d'intérêt
général
de la caisse des dépôts le constat qui
est fait que ces participations ont
souvent été nombreuses
pas suffisamment piloter historiquement
ou peut piloter historiquement avec une
attention insuffisante à la rentabilité
nous en sommes conscients et nous le
partageons nous estimons également que
ce sont des risques qui sont globalement
limités en termes de montants c'est un
inclut un montant très élevé c'est pas
non plus un risque qui financiers
illimités en très lourd quant à ce genre
d'intervention et vous avez indiqué tout
à l'heure que c'était un peu gérer comme
des subventions je crois que ça reflète
bien la réalité historique de ce que ça
peut être pendant un certain temps et
tout le tout le tout l'enjeu est de
sortir de cette de cette logique de ce
point de vue là la conclusion des
missions d'intérêt général n'est pas du
tout excuser d une recherche de
rentabilité et de prise en compte d'un
indicateur de rentabilité c'est un
facteur de sélection des projets ça ne
peut pas être qu'un seul que le seul
facteur mais c'est un facteur qui doit
est essentiel de ce point de vue là la
grille de cotation qui a été mise en
place est intéressante je sais pas si
elle doit pas être renforcés sur son
aspect rentabilité financière est un
autre point qui nous paraît très
important est de se donner un horizon
d'investissement on ne peut pas entrer
dans une scène parce qu'elle est liquide
et se dire qu'on y reste pendant des
décennies je pense que le taux de
rotation du portefeuille est peut-être
il ya une à rechercher dès l'entrée un
peu cet objectif taux de rotation du
portefeuille est quelque chose qui me
semble important sinon gel des
participations qui ont tendance à
devenir passive et ce n'est pas mon avis
le l'objectif logis cette ode à mort
c'est quelque chose
pas de rester durablement en capital de
c2c sel et quelques points qu'eux
que je voudrais indiquer ce qui a été
entrepris nous semble en cohérence avec
les conclusions qu'on peut tirer du
rapport de la cour
c'est quelque chose que nous sur lequel
nous insistons dans notre présence à la
la commission de surveillance au titre
de ses investissements mais au titre des
investissements d'intérêt général en
plus plus largement et je dirais que le
le caractère
un peu historique nous sommes quand même
déjà un petit peu dépassé il ya des
choses qui ont été entreprises et qui
vont largement dans le bon sens sur le
développement des cem leur utilité je
préfère laisser la parole à mon collègue
de la digicel monsieur le président je
peux indiquer en premier lieu que à
notre avis il peut être recommandé aux
collectivités qui envisage de créer une
société publique locale sur la base de
la loi du 29 mai d'entourer cette
création des garanties souhaitable pour
assurer la conformité avec le droit
européen
les sociétés publiques locales se
caractérise par ceux ci que la
collectivité peut contracter avec elle
sans organiser une mise en compétition
contrairement aux sociétés d'économie
mixte
mais cela à la condition que la société
publique locale rentrer dans le régime
dit de la coisy régie ou in house qui
correspond à deux critères à savoir que
la collectivité assure la société en
contrôle analogue à celui qu'elle a sur
ses propres services premier critère est
deuxième critère que la société exerce
avec la collectivité dont il s'agît
l'essentiel de son activité
le deuxième de ces critères je vais
commencer par celui là parce que c'est
celui qui soulève le moins de questions
est garantie en tout état de cause par
la loi elle même
en effet là où la jurisprudence
européenne dit que la société doit faire
avec la collectivité actionnaires
l'essentiel de son activité
le législateur a retenu un parti
beaucoup plus simple qui est de dire que
la société doit faire avec la
collectivité actionnaires à la totalité
de son activité
le législateur a précisé en outre que
l'action de la société sera limitée au
territoire géographique de ses membres
donc la loi n'a pas simplement des
calques et si je veux dire ou
paraphraser le droit européen
la loi c'est donner une marge de
sécurité à la tracer une ligne qui se
trouve clairement en deçà de la zone
d'incertitude éventuels que comporte le
droit européen pour le dire autrement
une collectivité qui se conforment
purement et simplement aux prescriptions
de la loi et par la mène et à plus forte
raison assuré d'être en règle à l'égard
du droit européen
voilà par rapport au deuxième critère
c'est à dire ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'obligation d'exclusivité le premier
critère c'est à dire que là où les
collectivités exerçant contrôle analogue
appel davantage de développement le
rapport fait par monsieur mézard pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi a
rappelle en quoi consiste aux yeux de la
jurisprudence européenne en contrôle
analogue
il rappelle en premier lieu que la
présence d'un actionnaire privé au
capital est exclu il rappelle en second
lieu que la jurisprudence européenne
permet que le contrôle analogue soit
assurée à plusieurs autrement dit il
peut y avoir contrôle analogue collectif
ce n'est pas exclue il indique en
troisième lieu que le contrôle analogue
n'est pas forcément contrôler
strictement identique à celui que la
collectivité aurait sur ses propres
services et enfin en dernier lieu il
démontre que la jurisprudence européenne
résonne in concreto c'est-à-dire
apprécié à travers un faisceau d'indicés
dans quelle mesure la collectivité
contrôler suffisamment ou ne contrôlent
pas suffisamment
la société dont il s'agit donc le
rapport montre de manière très claire à
partir d'un disque que dans deux
affaires par kilo brixen lescarbeau
thermo le juge européen a estimé que le
contrôle n'était pas suffisant dans une
troisième affaire république italienne
il a jugé que le contrôle était
suffisant
mais en examinant très concrètement la
manière dont le contrôle est effectué à
cet égard la loi contient par elle même
des gars rentrent en premier lieu la loi
elle même interdit la présence de
partenaires privés puisque par les cds a
maintenant que vous avez adopté il est
dit que il ne peut y avoir dans
l'actionnariat de la spl que des
collectivités ou bien leurs groupements
le droit commun des sociétés
commerciales garantie dans une certaine
mesure le contrôle puisque en tout état
de cause il est fait pour garantir les
droits de l'actionnaire le droit des
scènes auxquelles le gros dsl renvoi
largement donne des garanties aux
collectivités en ceci qu'il prévoit
qu'elles seront nécessairement par
exemple représenté au conseil
d'administration
il paraît prudent de considérer que au
delà du respect formel de ses
prescriptions légales la collectivité
pour être sûr d'être dans les noces aura
avantage à définir précisément les
modalités de son contrôle sur la société
puisque encore une fois ce sont ses
modalités concrètes qui intéresseront
qui intéresseront le le juge autrement
dit il suffira pas forcément
de dire la loi est observé à la lettre
il faut montrer qu'il ya effectivement
contre sur la sécurité juridique des
sociétés publiques locales là la cour le
rapport de la cour soulève deux
questions importantes
elle indique que se pose la question de
l'articulation entre la jurisprudence in
house et les règles relatives aux aides
d'état
autrement dit si la règle d'une heure
est satisfaite s'il ya bien contrôle
analogue est ce que il faut pas en outre
être en règle par rapport aux
dispositions qui encadre les aides aux
entreprises
notre sentiment est que la question ne
devrait pas se poser puisque dès lors
qu'il ya contrainte analogue on ne peut
pas s'aider soi-même et c'est en tout
cas la thèse que nous les femmes rang
devant l'union européenne à savoir que
la question des aides d'état ne peut pas
se poser concernant les espèces mais
nous devons reconnaître comme le dit la
cour qu'il n'existe pas de jurisprudence
européenne
sur ce point la cour fait notre
observation qui à notre avis doit
s'entendre comme comme étant aussi en
conseil indirects certes mais un conseil
aux collectivités locales concernées qui
est de veiller que l'action de la lp2 la
spl n'est pas pour conséquence de trop
restreindre la concurrence sur le marché
dont il va s'agir la cour consacre des
développements à la question de la
gestion du risque par la caisse en
indiquant en substance que dès lors
qu'il n'ya plus d'actionnaires privés
le risque pèsera davantage sur la
collectivité territoriale en pratique
les collectivités seront menées à
garantir davantage alors sans porter de
d'appréciation sur ce pronostic que je
peux je suis absolument pas en mesure de
confirmer ou de co2 ou de contester il
faut rappeler que l'ange à notre avis
est bien la maîtrise du risque global
c'est-à-dire non pas seulement le risque
que la caisse des dépôts subi comme
actionnaire ou bien dans le cas d espèce
comme simple prêteurs si dans
l'hypothèse où on leur prête c'est la
maîtrise du risque collectif subi tant
par la collectivité que par la caisse et
que par tout autre partenaire aussi bien
des dispositions légales limite les
garanties d'emprunt que les
collectivités ont le droit d'accorder le
par rapport à cette question de maîtrise
des risques peut-être la question des
montages complexes mériterait telle
attention notamment les phénomènes de
filialisation
une dernière question est évoquée dans
un article ii de la gazette des communes
de la semaine dernière 20 septembre
est ce que la société publique locale
être une alternative à
l'intercommunalité comme support de
mutualisation de services pour les
communes la l'article semble pencher
pour une réponse plutôt positive en
disant que la spl à par rapport à
l'intercommunalité l' avantage
une très grande souplesse mon sentiment
sera quelque peu différent me semble que
la législation actuelle et encore plus
ces évolutions en cours donne aux
collectivités notamment aux communes les
moyens de mutualiser leurs services tout
en restant dans le cadre d'institutions
à statut public
le projet de loi de réforme des
collectivités territoriales comporte des
dispositions à cet égard premièrement il
sécurise les mises à disposition de
services communaux en direction des opci
deuxièmement il permet aux pays de gérer
des services fonctionnels commun à leurs
communes membres
ce qu'on appelle la mutualisation
descendante
troisièmement il prévoit que les opci
adopteront un schéma de mutualisation de
leurs services reprenant cela des idées
inspirées
directement ou indirectement par le
rapport de monsieur richard le rapport
le match est d'allier le rapport de
monsieur warsmann c'est trois
dispositions mutualisation ascendante de
la commune a le pc mutualisation
descendante de le pca la commune schéma
de mutualisation ont été votés en termes
conformes identiques par les deux
assemblées parlementaires ou selon le
cas le seront qu'en l'assemblée
nationale aura procédé cet après-midi
pour ce qui la concerne vote solennel
voilà monsieur le président ce que je
pouvais dire sur les spectacles et en
juridique que au fond la société
publique locale c'est une sorte de
syndicat mixte
non c'est un instrument supplémentaire
n'est ce pas en tout cas nous sommes
n'avons plus de doute les participations
de la caisse sont en aucune façon des
subventions à l'aménagement locale ce
sont des participations gérée comme
telle et certaines d'entre elles
génèrent d'ailleurs enfin la plupart
joueurs des plus values en tout cas
souvent des dividendes même s'il reste
modeste par rapport à l'investissement
et puis ces entretiens les bonnes
relations entre la caisse et les
collectivités territoriales
et ça c'est précieux ça renforce un
climat de confiance aux autres à la
brique a demandé la parole monsieur le
président j'ai lu attentivement le
rapport de la cour comme souvent c'est
pas tout le temps mais souvent et j'ai
écouté les explications et de la caisse
et du trésor et pour dernière partie je
pense que l'intervention de monsieur del
sol été fort utile parce qu'elle elle
nous rappeler le droit et les eaux
claires et celles qui peuvent être à
risque à la fois pour les collectivités
locales pour la caisse notamment avec le
sujet des spl qui a été votée ici avec
une participation active de nos
collègues
alors ça m'amène à deux réflexions je
voudrais quand même livré à la
commission c'est que franchement en
lisant et en écoutant j'ai un peu perdu
le fil de la saisine
un par le 58,2 de la commission des
finances
j'avoue que je ne sais plus très bien ce
que nous cherchons d'accord bon ça c'est
le premier point et le et le deuxième
pour ben oui mais je le fais à
postériori maintenant et est le deuxième
point parce que ça a été évoqué par la
cour
et ça nous a été redit par la caisse et
je vous représente à la commission de
surveillance avec monsieur lambert ça ça
nous interroge nous législateurs tout ça
dans la mesure où nous aurions intérêt
on s'est peut-être focaliser sur la
société publique locale qui est un
nouvel outil juridique mais je pense
monsieur le président qu'on aurait
intérêt de ce point de vue à un moment
que moi j'ai souhaité quand même avec le
recul du temps assez rapide
justement par rapport à la
reconfiguration peut-être c'est
peut-être un peu ex-aequo ccif ce terme
mais je pense que notamment l'impact de
la loi elle m e sur qui on voit bien que
ça revient la notion d' investisseurs
avisés
elle est elle porte à conséquence dans
les orientations que la caisse est amené
à prendre et je pense que on voit bien
dans les rapports écrits que à la fois
cette notion d'investisseur avisé
c'est la loi lme de 2008 qui a consacré
le terme
pardon oui mais nous l'avons inscrit
dans notre législation explicitement non
non je ne vis pas fait pas bien je
trouve que c'est légal
jeudi qu' il faudrait voir concrètement
et à l'appui aussi de la cre
a sion par une proposition de loi des
spl et bien il faudrait faire une
évaluation de ces de ces dispositions
législatives
un vrai contrôle commun sur l'impact que
cela peut avoir pour les activités de la
caisse et comment elles mêmes saharien
réoriente la location de ses actifs bon
c'est évident que depuis deux ans sous
l'effet aussi de la crise économique
avec la création de fait si avec ce
qu'on va lui demander pour la poste
elle est particulièrement exigeante sur
l'allocation des actifs et la
rentabilité qu'elle en attend parce que
je pense que c'est quand même un point
essentiel pour nous donc voila un petit
peu ce que je souhaitais dire mais je je
considère que je les dis je ne sais pas
trop ce qu'on cherchait mais je
considère que c'était fort utile de
faire le point de doute on en était par
rapport aux évolutions du droit aussi ça
me paraît extrêmement important et je
vous remercie tous dit avoir chacun a
apporté sa contribution
2 elle est placée sous la surveillance
de la commission de surveillance mais
nous faisons l'hypothèse est ni ne
prenez pas mon propos en mauvaise part
que ses participations dans les sociétés
d'économie mixte locale pouvait être la
conséquence de considérations
historiques de l' influence de tel ou
tel élu territorial qui à un moment
donné avait souhaité l'accompagnement de
la caisse aussi bien sous forme d'apport
au capital des sociétés comics locale
nous avions souvenir de la grande
période d'aménagement ou la caisse des
dépôts étaient présentes partout et nous
demandions si finalement ccc société
d'économie mixte locale était vraiment
tout sous contrôle et nous souhaitions
avoir la avoir connaissance du pilotage
exercée par par la caisse sur ces
sociétés
et au fond ce que nous souhaitions
correspondent à des travaux déjà engagés
par la cour des comptes et on ne pas
surcharger la cour nous avons orienté la
deûle aux droits de tirage sur sur ce
thème et qu'ils rejoignaient les
préoccupations de la cour est donc je
rappelle que nos objectifs' était
d'établir une typologie des sociétés
d'économie mixte concernées ainsi qu'à
bilan de la diversité de leur statut et
leurs évolutions juridiques avec ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer à propos de
l'apport des sociétés publiques locales
de mesure et deuxième préoccupation la
valeur ajoutée apportée par la caisse
des dépôts et consignations dans ce type
d'activité et je pense que parmi la
valeur ajoutée hormis le fait qu'elles
sont vraiment sous contrôle chacune de
ses caisses
je pense que la présence d'un
représentant de la caisse
parmi les administrateurs peut-être
peut-être un activateur de de bonne
gouvernance pour ne pas laisser les élus
territoriaux entre eux voyez ce que ce
que je veux dire ceci n'est pas et en
aucune façon malveillants alors à leur
égard et puis enfin de porter une
appréciation sur la nouvelle doctrine
d'intervention de la caisse et elle nous
a été exposée magnifiquement par michel
bouvard rêve par augustin de romanet
alors j'ai plusieurs inscrits devraient
partager grâce à s'exprimer est ce qu'il
ya une priorité se poser un mot pour
revenir aux bonnes vieilles simple celle
d'autrefois celle de l'origine puisque
tout ça trouve son origine à l'époque de
françois bloch lainé
ce réseau a été constitué à cette époque
là il ya une cinquantaine d'années et il
était fédérer autrefois dans la set et
j'ai le souvenir que dans le passé on
avait pu critiquer certains
comportements en matière de frais de
gestion plus précisément de niveaux de
rémunérations de dirigeants de ces
sociétés ou bien reconnaître qu'il
pratique quand on est une collectivité
territoriale qu'on a un vieux secrétaire
général qu'il faut latéralisé vous que
l'on a besoin de compétences difficile à
rémunérer avec la grille de la fonction
publique territoriale d'utiliser des
organismes de ce type
bénéficiant d'une beaucoup plus grande
liberté de gestion
donc j'espère que tout ceci est vraiment
du passé
j'espère que compiègne n'a jamais eu de
société d'économie mixte un article de
foi
jamais ni offices hlm ni société connue
mixte rien de périphériques rien de
parallèle que la collectivité locale pur
et dur dans et pour des raisons
d'ailleurs de simplicité de gestion
simplement pour savoir ce qui se passe
et brett de ski parce qu'une scène
départementale alors il ya il y avait
une scène départementale que je n'ai
jamais fait travailler à compiègne
mais j'étais le vice président du
conseil de surveillance et donc j'y
allais bien volontiers parce que c'était
un lieu convivial et sympathique mais je
reviens quand même assez facilité de
gestion que lens est parfois donné par
l'utilisation d'outils comme les
sociétés d'économie mixte et ma question
s'adresse simplement à la caisse des
dépôts a la tutelle et à la cour des
comptes est ce que ce sont des sujets
sur lesquels vous êtes vigilant
on est absolument vigilant et lorsque je
disais tout à l'heure que le fait de se
retrouver entre soi dans une spl pouvait
avoir des inconvénients
c'est justement parce que nous nous
efforçons en tant qu administrateur de
la caisse des dépôts
nous demandons aux administrateurs etc
les dépôts qui sont dans les conseils
nutrition dsm d'avoir les mêmes règles
éthiques et déontologiques que celle
qu'ils ont dans les fonds
d'investissement qui sont financés par
prendre parfois ces investissements ou
dans tout autre organe de gouvernance
donc est ce que je peux répondre
définitivement oui à votre question je
dirai dans les instructions que je donne
sans aucun doute
j'ajouterai un point c'est que depuis
que je suis la caisse des dépôts je n'ai
jamais je dis bien jamais reçu une
sollicitation d'un de mes collaborateurs
ou d'année les locales pouvant me donner
à penser qu'il y aurait des abus donc si
d'aventuré cette situation existe elle
est rare et je pense que les montres les
motivations industrielle de
latéralisation auquel vous faites
référence on trouver des substituts
depuis il me semble t'il si je peux
ajouter un mot sur le président pas par
rapport aux interrogations de deux
filles marie dit bon je crois clair vous
comme lui il n'a pas de sem dans sa
commune bon mois il se trouve que je
suis lente dans un département où on a
pas mal de ce seuil économie mixte est
bon la présence de la caisse je crois
est une garantie d'un rapport notamment
aux problématiques de rémunération est
l'intérêt il vient en partie d'ailleurs
de ses héritages historiques évoqué
philippe marini de l'héritage de la
scène de l'héritage la sic et s'agissant
notamment des sem d'aménagement dont de
l'héritage la sède parce que finalement
c'est un vivier d'abord pour la gestion
des ressources humaines pour avoir un
encadrement et pour avoir justement des
références en matière de rémunération
parce que dès lors que vous allez
piocher dans ce vivier vous vous
efforcez en fonction de la taille de la
sem en fonction
l'endroit d'où vient votre directeur
vous avez des références et de cette
manière là vous éviter un certain des
cars et des personnels de qualité dans
lesquels vous pouvez aller piocher et
vous avez des références en matière de
rémunération et en matière de
déroulement de carrière donc c'est tout
de même quelque chose qui est ce qui est
important plus je voudrais revenir sur
un autre point
parce que j'ai compris que le président
de la commission des finances du sénat
se disait bon est ce que quand en clair
la caisse des dépôts mais un ticket dans
une sem est ce que quelque part c'est
pas une subvention déguisée
est-ce qu'on fait pas de la
débudgétisation en quelque sorte
alors moi je voudrais tout à fait clair
là-dessus bon tout d'abord la commission
de surveillance depuis trois ans et nous
partageons cette préoccupation avec
augustin de romanet fait la chasse à la
débudgétisation c'est pour ça qu'on a
voulu supprimer les bonifications
d'intérêts soffons d'epargne c'est pour
ça qu'on a souhaité que toutes les
conventions passées avec l'état passe
devant la commission de surveillance et
bien évidemment cette logique d'éviter
de la débudgétisation ou de la
subvention déguisée
elle existe également sur l'entrée au
capital d'une scène s'il ya une entente
à une entrée au capital d'une sem
c'est parce qu'il y a un projet c'est
parce qu'il ya des investissements et
les investit la part d'investissement
qui va être supportées au travers d'une
augmentation de capital
elle correspond je dire à une logique de
rentabilité moi j'ai vu plusieurs
dossiers passés dans la région dont je
suis élue sur des augmentations de
capital pas seulement dans mon
département pour porter un certain
nombre de projets d'investissements je
peux dire que le crible auquel le projet
est passé par les équipes des directions
régionales est un crible qui est
extrêmement précieux et qui permet
justement de s'assurer de la rentabilité
des projets et donc du fait que nous ne
sommes pas dans une logique
d'investissement à fonds perdus est donc
dans une logique de subventions
les emplois sont des emplois réels alors
monsieur le président je pense qu'il ya
deux éléments peut-être qu'on peut
donner un c'est que désormais les
rémunérations sont prises en charge par
les cem elle-même 1 ce qui est sans
doute plus sain que ce qui était le cas
autrefois
deuxièmement nous avons constaté que
dans certaines scènes mais c'était bien
entendu pas le cas général il y a
désormais des comités de rémunération
qui examine la rémunération du dirigeant
du directeur général de la société mais
ceci évidemment nous l'avons grosse tous
constaté ponctuellement notre enquête le
navet n'était pas exhaustive et il va de
soi que la pratique n'est pas
généralisée et maintenant à notre
collègue mézard cas rapportés la
proposition de loi sur les sociétés
publiques
merci monsieur le président très
simplement je voulais ayant été
rapporteur de ce projet de loi qui a été
votée à l'unanimité par les deux champs
indiqué qu'il ne s'agissait pas de de
créer un instrument pour détruire les
scènes mais qu'il s'agit d'un instrument
complémentaire d'un nouvel instrument et
après avoir écouté monsieur de romanet
je ne voudrais pas que ce nouveau
véhicule législatif soit dès l'origine
criblé d'un certain nombre de
projectiles nous avons en effet pris
toute une série de précautions pour être
en conformité avec la jurisprudence
européenne et en particulier avec
l'arrêt de 2008 coditel bravant que nous
avons pris la précaution dans les
travaux de commission de proposer toute
une série de sécurisation avec eux la
société anonyme au moins deux
actionnaires un objet social par
référence aux compétences des
collectivités territoriales et des spl
qui ne pourront travailler que sur le
territoire de ces collectivités
donc je crois qu'à ce niveau là on a
pris beaucoup de précautions
au niveau aussi des spl à dont le
potentiel d'action a été élargi par les
nouveaux textes et lorsque j'entends la
caisse des dépôts dire qu'avec tspl on
va se priver de conseils avisés
je pense que quand on se réfère à la
page 25 du rapport de la cour des
comptes de ses conseils n'ont pas
toujours été avisés pour avoir trois
sets sur ma communauté d'agglomération
j'ai pu voir que c'était pâques toujours
le cas on nous dit aussi que on se
priverait d'apporteur de fonds propres
qu'on perdrait l'effet de levier du
privé que nous n'aurions pas de
performances avec les spl et finalement
pour nous indique que les collectivités
locales pourrait conserver les cem et
donc les participations de la caisse des
dépôts par rapport aux autres avantages
extérieur qu'apporterait la caisse des
dépôts
je trouve que ça s'est fait pas c'est un
peu une pression qui est qui n'est pas
tout à fait pertinente et j'ajoute
monsieur le président que moi je crois
que les spl et les spl vont se
développer davantage que ce que l'on
peut penser à la lecture du rapport en
effet il ya la facilité pour la mise à
l'écart de la concurrence sur un certain
nombre de dossiers où cette concurrence
est mise en concurrence
amener des difficultés juridiques et
techniques terrible en particulier sur
nos petites et moyennes agglomérations
qu'en plus il faut pas rêver je le dis à
la caisse des dépôts la vente
la cession de la moitié de transdev et à
veolia va amener un certain nombre de
nos collectivités a changé les
perspectives en matière de transport par
exemple ce sont des choix qui le conte
il faudra assumer aussi donc je suis
convaincu moins que
après avoir aussi vu monsieur le
président par la gestion que j'ai pu à
laquelle j'ai pu participer que les spl
vont apporter un plus et que nous avions
et c'est pas fini quand même une
certaine d'imbrication de filiales
autour de la set je me suis rendu compte
après des années que une scène que je
présidais l'expert comptable était une
filiale de la caisse des dépôts sam
avait été cachée pendant plusieurs
années que le cabinet d'avocats avait
des liens étroits avec la caisse des
dépôts et j'en passe et il suffit de se
référer à la page 25 du rapport pour
savoir ce qu'il en était alors c'était
certes des conseils avisés très avisé
mais au delà des dividendes ça à porter
quand même une rémunération puisqu'il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont donc moins je crois que c'est
complémentaire je crois que on a un
instrument avec les spl qui est un bon
instrument qui ne remplacera pas
totalement les cem ni les avantages des
conseils souvent avisés c'est le cas de
la caisse des dépôts
mais qui permettra à nos collectivités
de disposer d'un instrument performant
mais à la vie de la caisse
on se sent pouvoir j'ai des polémiques
non je crois que ce que vous dites va
dans le sens de ce qu'a dit augustin de
romanet sur le fait que l'esp elles ne
sont pas l'ennemi des sem elles sont un
nouvel outil à côté mais elles ne
remplissent pas la même fonction
elles sont 100 % détenue par les
collectivités territoriales elles sont
in house elles doivent de règles assez
strictes et quand on a dit qu'il n'ait
pas d'effets de levier ça vaut pour la
caisse mais sa voix aussi tous les fonds
privés et on n'a pas de raison de mettre
plus en avant la caisse que les autres
sur ce sujet là donc je pense que ça
s'est assez factuels que l'effet de
levier est moindre il est vrai aussi
comme l'a dit madame briques que
l'introduction de ce dispositif
même si vous dites il crée un plus va
aussi changer et obligé y compris les
collectivités territoriales à se poser
la question du paysage des structures
d'intervention dans le domaine de
l'économie mixte puisque les scènes sont
mis en concurrence qui est d'ailleurs au
delà même de la gouvernance de la caisse
on essaye d impulser à travers l'action
de la caisse des dépôts il faut rappeler
que le fait d'être en concurrence est en
soi une corde de rappel par rapport à un
certain nombre de comportements qui
pourrait y avoir dans des sociétés
d'économie mixte ces comportements moi
je ne sais pas ils sont peut-être plus
facile à avoir sur ces dossiers des
sociétés 100 % détenue par les
collectivités locales et in house que
sur des sociétés mises en concurrence et
avec actionnariat privé
donc il va y avoir deux catégories de
sociétés certaines mises en concurrence
avec de l'actionnariat privé qui sont
par définition sur des marchés
différents et d'autres qui devront
veiller à rester dédiés à des besoins
spécifiques de lors de leur actionnaire
majoritaire
ça va je pense et c'est l'objet de la
stratégie mise en place et la caisse
obligés à repenser le paysage même des
scènes probablement et des
rationalisations futur et à mieux
discerner ce qui est du ressort de l'ain
de la sem est du ressort de la spl ce
qui va dans le sens de la stratégie que
nous essayons d'avoir en partenariat
avec les collectivités territoriales
contrôle
sujet que vous évoquez historique de
relations avec des parcours et des
filiales ou des prestataires de service
de la caisse ou l'ass est bon ça a été
dit tout à l'heure par la cour des
comptes il ya maintenant une
dissociation entre l'actionnariat d'un
côté et des filiales qui remplissent des
prestations de services qui dans le
groupe caisse des dépôts le droit
d'exercer des activités concurrentielles
et qui le font dans le cadre des règles
de mise en concurrence vis-à-vis des
sociétés d'économie mixte il est
président c'est le mans pour pour
revenir ce que je paquet d'équivoque
comme notre réunion est retransmise et
est suivi à l'extérieur il n'y a pas de
vente par la caisse des dépôts de la
moitié de transdev et à veolia
il y à une fusion à parité entre deux
sociétés et avec une présidence de la
nouvelle société qui sera assumée par
veolia une direction générale par
transdev avec un plan d'affaires commun
qui a été rédigé et avec le respect des
orientations qui ont été prises par
transdev vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales qui ont fait
confiance à la caisse pour leur confier
leur le réseau de transport après au
terme des concessions évidemment les
collectivités sont libres de pouvoir
faire faire d'autres choix d'agir il n'y
a pas de vente de la moitié de transdev
à veolia nous sommes bien dans une
opération qui est différente
quelle nature à renforcer la concurrence
en levant la caisse qui ne renforcera
pas la concurrence mais qui prend en
compte une concurrence qui devient
beaucoup plus large dans le secteur du
transport public à l'exception de
l'ile-de-france la région parisienne
mais ça c'est bon c'est un fait
historique
on a de grands opérateurs étrangers qui
arrivent maintenant dans le secteur du
transport public dont le pays des
chinois de hong kong des espagnols
oui c'est ça et à l'échelle du monde
mais néanmoins quand on fait des appels
d'offres au plan départemental pour le
transport scolaire
les acteurs se raréfient et nous avons
quelques convictions libérales et nous
interrogeons sur la logique de ces
concentrations
c'est comme le too big to fail voyez
vous
jusqu'où doit-on aller est-ce que ce
qu'il n'y a pas un moment donné une
logique financière qui tente à se
substituer à la logique de service
public quoi monsieur alduy
oui beaucoup de choses ont été dites
mais je voudrais aller dans le même sens
que notre collègue mesdames je suis
totalement convaincu que l'espagne vont
se développer et qu'elles vont prendre
une grande part du marché aujourd'hui
occupé par les scènes alors pourquoi les
cem historiquement c'était une puissance
financière puissance technique pas de
mise en concurrence et en contrepartie
c'était pas les collectivités qui
prenait tous les risques peu à peu la
puissance financière est parti la mise
en concurrence est arrivé le réseau
technique c'était de l'est et a pu de
prise de risque
les collectivités garantissent tous
égards disent tous les opérations en
compte propre d'une sem sont rarissimes
rare ici donc évidemment lorsqu'on est
dans cette situation là pourquoi
s'enquiquiner à faire des appels
d'offres compliqué alors qu'avec une
espèce là ça va plus vite et comme de
plus en plus c'est la maîtrise d'un
calendrier qui fait la réussite d'une
opération
on souhaite la plupart des collectivités
locales gérées de manière précise les
calendriers donc je suis totalement
convaincu que l'aspect la va se
développer
et donc ça m'a interpellé la caisse des
dépôts et je pose la question suivante
est ce que il ne va pas falloir demain
avoir une complémentarité une
coexistence entre les deux systèmes où
on remettra les cem à leur place dans le
temps c'est à dire une société qui prend
des risques et c'est pas la collectivité
qui prend tous les risques avec à côté
ça en effet les sp là qui ne sont en
fait qu'une ma nation des collectivités
est une façon plus active de faire
fonctionner service public quand je dis
plus active et surtout plus transparente
avec une bière une une facilité pour
mesurer les dépenses et les coûts pour
mettre en place des mécanismes de
comptabilité analytique et c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien que c'est une
modernisation des services publics avec
un effet tous les aspects mutualisation
que l'on pourra développer avec
l'extension des dde pc de
l'intercommunalité
il faudra donc à côté que les sociétés
que mx reprennent leurs fonctions deux
sociétés à risque de sociétés qui font
des opérations en compte propre
à partir de là on va avoir une
complémentarité alors il faut que cette
orientation se prises rapidement
parce que si on se met à transformer à
supprimer les cem et unes après les
autres pour passer à des spl aider ce
pays là et bien la fin il y aura pas de
complémentarité et on aura un système
privé d'un côté et le système d'espoir
au milieu de l'autre est plus du tout de
d'économie mixte entre les deux et moi
je suis un adepte de l'économie mixte à
condition que le partenariat en question
soient pas simplement la collectivité
prend tous les risques et de temps en
temps on voit des conseils avisés
cela dit j'ai bien aimé
lorsque directeur général a affirmé je
m'arrêterai là dessus nous n'avons pas
de logique de pouvoir et j'aimerais que
ce message a eu jusque tout en bas de la
caisse des dépôts et que notamment nous
il n'y ait pas une sorte de de pression
sur les collectivités du style si vous
faites sp là on sera pas là dedans tel
est l endroit dentelle et elle elle dans
tel et tel partenariat
parce que ce type de chantage évidemment
peut en agacer plus d'un dont je fais
partie toute poursuite à donner nous
l'imaginions extrêmement riche tout à
fait interactive elle est allée au delà
nos espérances grâce à chacun d'entre
vous je remercie monsieur le président
de la première chambre messieurs les
conseillers m vous madame le rapporteur
le président de la commission de
surveillance le directeur général qui a
dû nous quitter mais nous savions ses
contraintes ses ses adjoints la
direction générale des collectivités
locales la direction générale du trésor
merci à chacun d'entre vous mesdames et
messieurs les résultats de cette enquête
pour finalement faire l'objet d'une
publication
prochain rendez vous à 16h 30 vous
pourrez suivre les débats sur le projet
de loi nome sur la nouvelle organisation
du marché de l'électricité vous pouvez
également retrouver tous nos décryptage
politique et parlementaire sur notre
site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur notre chaîne